PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Good morning.
I just love that code.
Every successful user
is not just a number.
It's a whole life,
a whole new story.
Thank you Florian,
[? Pranshu, ?]
Brett, and Oded for sharing
those remarkable stories
with us.
And thank you to each one of
you for building those apps
and games that
impact so many lives
and write so many
beautiful stories.
Welcome to Playtime 2017.
[APPLAUSE]
Be it an app that helps
you communicate better,
get healthier, learn a
language, or a game that
provides pure
entertainment or an avenue
for self-expression or
learning a new skill, your apps
and games impact people who are
on two billion Android devices.
Just think about
that for a moment.
Amazing, isn't it?
And if you see the stories
that we just showed you,
you realize that the connection
between the app and the user
goes way beyond the technical
features that it provides.
We, on Android and
Play, are humbled
to provide a small
part of the technology
to make those
connections possible.
In addition to
building great apps,
you have told us that you
want to support causes
that matter to you.
Today, I'm super
excited to announce
the first of those initiatives
of supporting these causes.
We have partnered
with these developers
to support World Food
Day, a program that
creates activism
and brings attention
to people who are suffering
from hunger around the world.
Throughout this
week, we will promote
these 11 apps and games.
And 100% of the proceeds of
all key item in those apps
and games will be donated
to the World Food Program.
Give these developers
a big hand.
I would also ask each one of
you, take out your phones,
download these apps
and games, play them.
Thank you for your generosity.
In the coming months,
we look forward
to working with more of you to
find causes that matter to you
and support more things
with bigger social impact.
So here we are, Playtime 2017.
We were just talking about it.
Four years ago, this was
a tiny little program
in a small little room
on the Google campus.
And today, you join
a global series
of events with hundreds
of top developers
across Berlin, Sao Paolo,
Shenzhen, Singapore,
Seoul, and Tokyo.
I can't even keep track of the
places that this is happening
and where we bring top
developers together
to learn what's latest at Google
as well as from each other.
So what's the day
going to look like?
We're going to
kick off by talking
to you about what's latest
from Google in the morning.
We also have IDEO coming
up here and talking
to us about building
apps and games using
immersive technologies.
In the afternoon, you
will hear from each other
about best practices,
about building great games,
driving engagement, launching
successfully, and keeping
your user happy.
Throughout this day, we're
going to have one team that will
come up over and over again.
And that is about
sustainable engagement.
As you listen to
the tools that we
are going to provide you
to engage your users,
I ask you to think
about this theme
and ponder on a few questions.
What does sustainable
engagement mean for you
in your app or game?
Are you seeing your
users hitting capacity?
What metrics are you using to
know what engagement is good
and maybe what isn't?
How will we collectively
build a happy user
base for a long time?
These are important questions
for all of us in the industry,
because they have significant
impact on our businesses,
but also for our responsibility
towards our users.
And these are
difficult questions.
We hope to continue the
dialogue we start here today
to find answers for
these questions.
I speak for everyone
on Google Play when
I say I'm super excited that
we have you all here today
together.
At the end of this day,
I hope you will tell us
that you heard something
that excited you
and, more importantly, that you
met somebody who inspired you.
And with that, let's
kick off Playtime.
I'm going to call on stage,
Vineet to talk about Google
Play product vision.
VINEET BUCH: Thanks, Purnima.
Hi, I'm Vineet Buch.
I am responsible for
the product team that
does the Play Store,
the Play Console,
as well as Instant Apps.
So Google has been
building mobile platforms
for a while, obviously,
began with Android.
We've expanded that now to cover
everything from watches to TVs
to cars.
Play is the glue that binds
these platforms together.
It's what brings these
platforms to life
by delivering apps and games
that our users want to actually
really get benefit
of these platforms
and, at the same time,
of course, helping
you, our developer partners,
build meaningful, sustainable
businesses on these platforms.
So I'm going to walk
you through some
of the big things we're thinking
about for the next year plus
and then the lead from
different parts of Play
are going to dive into
details through the course
of the morning.
We're very proud of
the success that we've
had in growing the store,
in growing the developer
ecosystem.
But with this
growth, we definitely
have faced some challenges.
For the user, the challenge is
that now there's two million
plus apps and games,
which one should they use?
Which one should they
install, download, play with?
And for you, for
our developers, how
do you get to the
users who actually
will care about your app?
How do you actually get
them to engage more deeply
and to reengage with an app
they may have on their phone,
but may not even remember
they have on their phone?
And if you've invested in
building an app or game that
really deeply pulls
in the user, how
do you get the benefit
of that in terms
of attracting new users?
Well, we've been thinking a
lot about all of these issues.
And we've seen that, for
the store, browse traffic--
that's people who come to the
store and come to the home page
and say, I'm bored,
show me something--
that's really grown.
And so how do we help solve
some of these problems?
Well, one thing is that,
in terms of our ranking,
in terms of our
personalization, we
should really reward
developers who've
built apps and games
that are deeply engaging.
In the past-- we're Google.
We use this kind of data.
We've used things like
click data and install data,
but we haven't, until
recently, started
using engagement data in our
ranking, and now we are--
normalized across
categories, of course.
We are leveraging
things like, this app
seems to engage
users a lot more.
We should probably
rank it higher.
Because users seemed
to like this more than
the norm for this category.
So we're using
that kind of data.
We invested a lot in
building our personalization
in the store.
Really our mission
is, for the user,
to find a store that
they feel is really
tailored to themselves,
that sort of speaks to them.
We've made big strides.
Not quite all the way there yet,
but when we look at our metrics
around this, it's
quite impressive
how much we've been
able to improve
the user believing that
this store is really
tailored to them.
We're also trying to
do a number of things
around reengaging users with
the apps and games they already
have.
Kara will talk some more about
this subsequently to this.
But in a nutshell, we've made
new destinations for games.
We've brought in
things like live event
feeds into the store.
And in general, as we measure
ourselves with new launches,
we're thinking not just of
new high quality installs,
but also helping users
rediscover something
they already may
have on their phone.
We had a big announcement
around the general availability
to developers of Android
Instant Apps IO this past May.
I'm very happy to say
that the store is now
getting behind driving
traffic to Instant
Apps in a very big way.
The first step-- this is an
experiment where we've launched
recently--
in addition to just being
able to install an app,
users will be able to try it
with a simple one button press,
as though they
already had the app.
In fact, the
example you see here
is the ShareTheMeal app
that Purnima talked about.
You want to spread some joy.
You want to share some benefit.
You just click one button.
Boom, it's right there.
It's no secret that a lot of
the growth for the Android
ecosystem is
happening in markets
like India, Indonesia, Brazil--
lots of users,
lots of new users.
And also not surprising
that many of these new users
encounter the very first
smartphone, which may actually
be constrained in terms
of memory, storage,
and maybe on a somewhat
bandwidth-constrained network.
We are launching Android Go, a
streamlined version of Android,
to be optimized for these
kind of devices and networks.
It's rolling out in the
next couple of months.
We also are going to make
the store in these markets
leaner, slimmer, et cetera.
And we're hoping
to really present
apps and games in
these markets that are
optimized for these conditions.
We, for a while, had the
next guidelines for building
for these kinds of
devices and users.
A number of developers
are already adopted these.
We encourage you to
take a look at these,
if you have yet,
and see how you can
benefit from this user growth.
In the store, we will,
for users on these devices
in these markets,
be prioritizing apps
that are optimized for them.
So if, for example
you've got a lite app,
or if you slim down your
app, we will be making sure
the user gets to see
that as a high priority.
So in closing, I
just want to say
that through the course
of today, this afternoon,
we'll have product managers
and developer relations teams
from across different
parts of Google
available for one-on-one
sessions with you.
Please, take advantage of this.
The agenda will explain
who is available when.
But definitely make sure that
you come with your questions,
with your thoughts,
with your comments.
And if you want to run ideas
by us, we're here for you.
Please, take advantage of this.
With that, I'll
ask Matt Henderson,
who's our lead for
the Play Console
to give you some more
details about that.
MATT HENDERSON: Lots of great
stuff to share with you today.
So two billion devices
publishing software
to two billion devices.
It's a tremendous opportunity,
but it's also challenging.
And so it's important
that we build tools
to help support your success.
Play can help you
iterate on your app
to get it to high quality prior
to release and post-release.
During the release
process, we can help you
to mitigate risks that come up.
Our tools can also help
you to understand business
opportunities and take
advantage of those business
opportunities.
On the quality side,
earlier this year at IO,
we announced Android
Vitals in the Play Console.
Android Vitals is a
program to help you build
apps and games of high quality.
How important is quality?
50% of one star rated reviews
on Play mention app stability
and bugs.
So if you want to avoid
one star rating reviews,
this is a great thing
to invest time in.
We're really excited that
just since IO, Android Vitals
has really been embraced.
So already 65% of
top developers are
using Android Vitals
to help learn how they
can improve their app quality.
Vitals helps you
understand three areas
of bad user experience
across stability, battery,
and rendering.
From today, five new metrics
are launching in Vitals
to help you understand
problems more deeply.
For app stability,
Vitals now reports
when the same user
session is affected
by multiple ANRs and crashes.
These repeated problems
caused use of frustration,
leading to risk of uninstall.
For battery, Vitals
now highlights
when excessive activity takes
place in the background,
leading to unnecessary
battery drain.
For example, we now report
excessive Wi-Fi scans
and excessive network usage
in the background, as well
as stuck wakelocks.
Until now, Android Vitals
has generated metrics
from users on the Nexus
and pixel devices.
Today, our coverage
expands dramatically.
It's up 25-fold from
just earlier in the year.
It's a huge increase
and includes
a spectrum of flagship devices
and mid-range devices as well.
We've also revamped
the Android Vitals
section in the Play Console
with a richer user experience.
There's an overview
for metric at a glance.
There's time series charts.
There's also benchmarks, so you
can compare your own metrics
against the metrics of
other developers as a whole.
As you improve your
app quality, we
want to make sure that end users
find those great experiences.
That's why Android Vitals and
now our key signal for Google
Play and a number of user-facing
areas, our search and discovery
algorithms take Vitals into
account when they favor apps
with better vitals.
And vitals are an
important signal
when your app is
being considered
for promotional opportunities,
like the new and updated
collection, editor's choice
collection, the Google Play
Awards, and the
recently launched,
Android Excellence Program.
The pre-launch report is
a way to improve quality
before the app's published.
It automatically crawls
and tests your APKs
on a variety of
different devices,
looking for crashes and security
vulnerable vulnerabilities.
And what we've observed
is 90% of the time
that the pre-launch report
testing robot discovers crashes
in an app, the developer chooses
not to take that app forward
into production.
It's modified before
going into production.
So this is really working
well at identifying
problems that are then fixed
before going out to real users.
From today, every
APL that's submitted
to alpha and beta track is going
to get a pre-launch report.
So this is dramatically
expanding the availability
of the program.
We're also launching
a new robot tester
that reaches deeper into
the app and discovers
more crashes, more problems.
We're adding new
performance metrics as well
to the pre-launch report,
covering CPU, memory, network,
and rendering.
App security is another key part
of the quality user experience.
And Play's security team
sends security recommendations
to thousands of developers
to help fix vulnerabilities.
Today, we're further investing
in security with the Google
Play Security Reward Program.
Here's how it works.
To start with, we'll be inviting
developers of popular apps
to opt into the program.
Participating
security researchers
will try to find vulnerabilities
in those eligible apps.
They submit the
vulnerabilities in a report
via your bug reporting process.
And our partner, HackerOne, can
set up a free reporting process
if you don't already have one.
Once the vulnerability
is fixed, the researcher
reports it to the Play Store.
And the security
reward program will
generate a reward, a payout
from Google to that researcher.
Google's security team
will then scan all apps
for that vulnerability and
send security recommendations
to any other
affected developers.
Some of Google's security team
and some of the HackerOne team
are here today.
So if you want to learn
more, chat further with them.
I encourage you to do so.
Tools in the Play
Console can also
help you mitigate risks when
you're targeting and releasing
your app to your audience.
Alpha and beta testing has been
one of the features at Play
that developers
really love most.
More than 300,000 developers
use alpha and beta tracks.
We've got some new
capability that we're
adding to that-- country
targeting at the track level.
So until today,
country targeting
was fixed across
all track states.
But now, you can beta test
in specific countries.
So you can beta
test in country A
before launching in
that country publicly,
even though your app may be
fully launched in country B.
In the coming weeks, we're going
to be also launching country
targeting in stage rollouts.
So for a new release
of an existing app,
you may use stage rollouts
to increase that release
to specific percentages
of production users.
And with country
targeting, you'll
be able to control which
countries that process is
happening to over time.
The device catalog
was also a new feature
we announced to IO
this year, and it's
been tremendously popular.
So this is a tool where
you can search devices
by attributes, like RAM, system
on chip, screen size, and more.
It shows you your
app's performance
for specific devices.
And you can set
targeting rules if you
want to exclude some
devices if they're not
suitable for your app.
We're now launching
a new feature
that allows you to save
device search queries.
So if you have a combination
of filter settings
that, perhaps, gets you large
screen devices that are running
Android O and meet a
certain bar for RAM size,
then you can save
that as a custom query
and use it again in the
future and more quickly
navigate to it in the future.
Another cool feature
we're adding here
is based off questions that we
receive from developers often,
which is, why isn't this
specific device supported
by my app?
So in the device catalog,
we're launching today
a feature where we answer
that exact question.
You can pick a specific
device in the device catalog.
And it will tell you
reasons why your app doesn't
support that device.
For example, on the screen
here, the production APK
requires accelerometer feature.
And the beta APK requires the
camera autofocus feature, which
this device doesn't support.
So you can go into
the vast catalog
and find those sorts
of reasons to help
you understand what's going on.
We continue to add features
to the Play Console
to help you grow your business.
And subscriptions are the
fastest growing developer
business model.
We have new features
to help with that.
So easier set up means you
can launch your subscription
app faster.
We recently announced
the official release
of the Play billing library.
And this simplifies
the development process
for Google Play
billing by making sure
that you're always using the
latest in-app billing features.
Were making it easier for you
to test your payment flows
by providing a good form of
payment and bad form of payment
for each license test account.
So you can test without having
to use a real payment method.
We're also updating the
subscription settings
in the Play Console.
So you can configure
your subscription SKUs
at an app level.
Now your business can't
survive if you don't get users.
Our research has shown
that 78% of subscribers
start with a free experience.
So we're introducing
improvements to our free trial
logic to make it smarter.
In order to reduce
free trial abuse,
we're now enforcing the users
one free trial at the app
level.
And you can manage that
sitting in the new subscription
settings page on
the Play Console.
This setting is available
today, and enforcement
is going to start in
December of this year.
We've heard feedback from
developers that some of you
would like to have shorter
free trial lengths.
So now, the minimum free trial
length will be three days.
For those of you
with content costs,
this lowers the marginal
cost of acquisition.
While acquiring
users is important,
you can't stay in business
long if you don't keep them.
At IO, we talked
about a new feature
called the account hold.
And I'm pleased to
announce that it's
now open for
general availability
and can be implemented by
checking the account hold
box in the subscription
setting in Play Console.
We're also launching a
new win back features.
So starting today, we're going
to notify you immediately
when a subscriber's state
change, including cancellation.
So no more waiting until the end
of the month to check the API
and find out that a subscriber
cancelled two weeks ago.
Instead, you can
understand immediately
and trigger communication
to the user,
especially if there's something
new that may entice them
to retain the subscription.
Maybe they didn't know
about a new feature.
Maybe they didn't
know about a new show
that you had just launched.
And so these win back
features, we think,
can help you to
increase user retention.
Also starting today,
we're giving users
the ability to restore
a subscription that
hasn't completely expired.
So they had a subscription,
they unsubscribed,
but they have the
ability to restore that
without going through the
whole subscription creation
funnel again.
And we think that's
going to remove
some of the friction for them
to get started and remain
in the relationship, in the app.
You can opt into that
subscription restoration
setting through the
new subscription
settings in the Play Console
as well, so lots of stuff.
We hope the new
features help, as you
continue to build
amazing apps and games.
And Kara is now going to share
some news about the Play Store.
Thanks.
KARA BAILEY: Before I get
started, I, first of all,
wanted to say a big
thank you to all of you
for the very, very hard
work you do day in,
day out in creating really
great user experiences.
It makes my job easier.
But most importantly,
it really enables
us to really deliver great
content that creates user
experiences across our users.
So today, I'm going to talk
about some changes we've
made on the Play
Store to really make
it easier for users to
discover and to engage
with our great content.
So as Vineet mentioned,
Play's mission
is to bring devices to
life on mobile and beyond.
Whether for you phone,
watch, or even your car,
Play is a thread that connects
two billion devices to content
that makes them truly magical.
Now personalization here
is the building block.
That's made even more
powerful by having
great content to recommend
and great services
for those recommendations.
I want to share with you some
of the way that we have improved
our personalization
over the last year,
as well as walk through
some of the ways
that we're creating new
experiences to give users
a much better way to engage with
the content in the Play Store.
So a lot of the magic of
Play's recommendations
happens behind the scenes.
So I want to pull back
the curtain a little
and give you some insight into
how we match the right content
to the right user.
To help users explore,
we've built a taxonomy
that really creates thousands
and thousands of topics that
enables a user to go
much deeper into content
and also gives the
user more control.
We've used this,
as you'll see here,
in the recently launched
search refinements, where
a user can make
choices in delving down
into the content that's
of interest to them.
We've also used this to power
really great recommendations
across our homepages.
We've also improved our ranking
to make it more contextually
relevant and also much fresher.
So for example, for a football
fan here on the right,
we know that person is
interested in football.
And so we surface this
content much more prominently
in the store, given that users
interests, as well as the fact
that it's a trending topic.
Across all our efforts, as
you heard from both Purnima
and Vineet, we
really are thinking
about ongoing engagement
and reengagement
And so you'll see here
our don't forget to try,
which surfaces apps that a
user has recently installed.
So within our
recommendations, we
want to also help users
to decide what to install.
There's so many things.
But what should
they really install?
So we want to highlight
the best of the catalog.
We've always had editorial
curation at Play,
but it's not always
been clear to a user
what's editorial versus
other recommendations
and why we're
highlighting it to them.
So a major focus
of this year has
been on creating new editorial
experiences, including
rich, long form content,
as you'll see here,
which shows to users the
reasons why we love this.
Three great reasons
why we think this
is a great app or game a
user should engage with.
This editor's choice is
now live in 17 countries
around the world.
And in future, we'll be
integrating this not just
in its own section, but
it will be integrated
in other parts of the Play
Store to really help users
throughout their
discovery experience.
So a large part of editorial
is Play having an opinion
about what's best for users.
And so we'll be using
these richer content
experiences to highlight
the best content
that we have in our events,
such as Best of Play.
We really want to be able
to recognize and reward you,
as developers, who create
this great content.
And there is a spot
here coming up later
this year where you'll
see our Best of Play 2017.
So we also want
to recognize those
that take full advantage
of the Android platform
through programs like
Android Excellence, which
you'll see here on the right.
This will be refreshed
each quarter.
And you can reach
out to your BD team
for any further information.
We know how important
games are to our users.
And I want to share
several changes
we're making on the Play
Store to really create
a much more engaging
browse experience.
One that really does bring users
back continually to the store
to engage and reengage
with our great content.
So let's start with navigation.
Now I know it's very
obvious, but games
are different from
apps, and so we're
reflecting that in elevating
games to its own destination.
Now we do hope and
expect that will
help drive more users into games
to discover that great content.
But it also provides
an excellent foundation
for creating experiences that
are really unique to games,
such as immersive
recommendations that
highlight videos, screenshots
of actual game play.
We also want to give users
more control over how they
browse that games experience.
So an example here is we've
created a premium section
within games that
highlights paid games.
And this launched last month.
This is also great
for showcasing games
on sale using the new
strikethrough price
feature that really
enables a user
to see the value that
you're delivering.
To date, given this
was launched a month,
we're seeing really
great engagement,
where users are going
much further and deeper
into the content and really
engaging with many more
of our premium games.
Newness is really
important to our gamers.
And so this is a topic
that we're approaching
in a few different ways.
Similarly to
premium games, we're
experimenting with a new
section on new games.
So this highlights some
of our best new games
across our popular franchises,
as well as our amazing indies.
We're also exposing
preregistration
in many more places through
the store as well as much more
prominently.
So we do hope that
this will give users
a sense of what's coming
up soon and enable
you, as developers, to build
momentum behind a new game
launch.
You'll see here also
that another example
of an experiment
that what we're doing
is experimenting with
preregistration rewards.
And this is shown on
the store listing page
with the example of
our Angry Birds Match.
Again, we look out for
more of these things that
are coming up in the next
few months and into 2018.
And finally, we are also making
our top charts more responsive.
So we'll be updating them
multiple times each day
to ensure that we really
are bringing freshness
and newness to the store.
But as Purnima and
Vineet both touched on,
the store really does need to do
much more than just help users
find a new game
or app to install.
We really want to
create and are working
to create a
destination for users
to find out what's
happening in the games
that they already play.
So here, you'll
see we've started
highlighting major in-game
events through store featuring.
And these have had
a great reaction
from users who are really
engaging and reengaging,
as well as producing great
results for developers.
So you'll start to
see many more live ops
through the store in different
parts of the store coming up
and into 2018.
You'll see an example of this
is the live ops card on Games
home, which highlights exciting
events happening in the games
that a user is playing
or has installed.
And this encourages that
user to really get back
into the content and really make
sure that they don't miss out.
And lastly, we also
want to make sure,
through don't forget
to play, that we're
creating every opportunity
to recommend and ensure
users are engaging
with the content
that they're interested in.
So that was a lot on
games, but what about apps?
We're also looking to drive
ongoing engagement with apps
by really ensuring that
users can get the most out
of the apps that
they already have.
Starting with
entertainment, we're
taking a much more
content-forward approach,
which you can expect to see
more of across other categories
in future.
So here's an example of
what we mean in practice.
So we're able to
use the information
about the content in each
app to power a better search
experience.
So in this case, a user
is interested in "Game
of Thrones."
Now while that user
might be looking
for an app or a game related
to "Game of Thrones,"
we know that they're probably
looking to watch the show.
So in this case, we can surface
the HBO GO app and the HBO Now
app and make it clear to
users that they can stream
and watch "Game of Thrones"
through both of those apps.
We've also started to
highlight major in-app content
moments through store
featuring, and we're
experimenting with
other dedicated services
through the store to surface
these content moments.
So this is an example here,
working in partnership with HBO
Now to surface many of the
different shows, where we make
it clear to users that you can
either subscribe to the app
or you can purchase
the episodes, so again,
giving users multiple
ways to engage
with the content that
they're interested in.
So as Vineet said, continuing
with the theme about the Store
being about more
than just installs,
we're really excited to
announce the first integration
with Android Instant Apps
within the Play Store.
You can see here
the Try Now button,
which really encourages users
to jump right into the content.
This addresses
users immediately,
right in the moment.
We will be experimenting
with different ways
to surface this to
users, so expect
to see more on this next year.
So that was quite a lot.
But I'm really excited about
the new experiences that we're
creating and the new content
types that we're developing.
This gives users new ways
to explore the catalog
and gives them lots more reasons
to come back to the store
and continue to explore
the store along the theme
of continued engagement,
ongoing engagement,
and, obviously, reengagement.
Expect to see a lot
more on that in 2018.
So now over to Shahid, who's
going to talk about Chrome.
SHAHID HUSSAIN: Hi, everyone.
My name's Shahid.
I'm a product manager
on the Chrome OS team.
Before I jump into
what we're going
to talk a little
bit about today,
can I just ask how many of you
are familiar with Chrome OS?
Maybe you've used it.
How many of you
have a Chromebook?
OK, awesome.
Thank you for using
it, trying it.
We're very excited to
be here at Playtime.
And what we wanted
to do is share
with you a little bit of an
introduction to Chrome OS
and how apps can work
on that platform.
So for those of you who are
maybe a little less familiar,
let me maybe start with
some of the basics.
So Chrome OS, since we
started building a product,
has been about
these three things--
speed, simplicity, and security.
We want Chrome OS to be
a fast operating system.
Fast to start, fast to use.
We want it to be
simple, easy to use.
We think of Chrome OS like
a tool that just disappears
and lets you, as a user, get
on with whatever you were there
to do.
And we want it to be secure.
That's been core to the way
we've built Chrome OS ever
since we first started.
So that set of ideas, which
has been very constant,
has led us to some success.
Chromebook shipments overtook
Macs in the United States
last year.
And for those of you who
are familiar with Chrome OS,
we're very strong in
the education space.
Chromebooks actually
outsell every other device
combined in education.
But it's not only
in education space
where we're growing
and getting stronger.
We've seen nearly 20%
year-on-year growth in retail.
And we'll be
continuing to invest
in the success of Chromebooks
across the company
the end of this year and
over the next few years.
The Chrome OS team is
new here at Playtime,
because the Play Store is
fairly new to Chrome OS.
So last year at IO, we announced
the availability of Google Play
on Chrome OS.
And we've been working hard to
improve how Play and Android
apps work on Chrome OS.
Just a couple of weeks ago,
we worked with our colleagues
in the Google hardware team on
the launch of the new Google
Pixelbook.
And the Pixelbook is
really a next step
in the evolution of the
Play Store on Chrome OS.
And we feel the quality
of the experience
and the quality of the
apps running on it is good.
But it's not just Chrome OS
when we think about Android
apps running on the desktop.
Chrome OS is what we do.
But also, we work very
closely with teams
like the Samsung team, who have
decks built into their product.
So we're expecting
to see more and more
of that desktop projection
activity running on mobile.
And that is very, very similar.
Essentially,
Android apps running
inside a desktop environment.
So that's one of the
reasons why we think this
is important for developers.
The types of apps,
though, can be different.
So for me personally, when I
use apps on my mobile phone,
I tend to use it
in short bursts.
And when I pay for
apps on mobile,
I tend to spend
just a few dollars.
But on desktop, the kinds
of apps that I'll use,
I will use hours at a time
or for many hours at a time.
And I'm happy to spend up
to a few hundred dollars
because often the usage
is professional in nature.
So these really simple
changes in the form factor--
going to a bigger screen,
getting faster inputs
with mouse and keyboard--
drive a different kind of usage.
And that's been reflected
in our analytics
when we look at how
people are using apps
on these two platforms.
So immersive apps, like
Skype, Sin City, AutoCAD 360,
our analytics tell us
that users spend more time
in that app on a Chromebook
than they do on a smartphone
because the type of
usage can be different.
So now that we've talked a
little bit about the why, what
I'd like to do is share
with you, briefly,
some thoughts on how you
can help optimize your app,
so it runs really well inside
a desktop operating system,
like Chrome OS.
So first of all, Chromebooks
work like any other Android
device.
If you have an app on
the Google Play Store,
it probably already
works on Chrome OS.
And for those of you who
have Chrome OS devices,
I hope you've had a chance
to go into the Play Store
on those devices and check
out your apps running
there are already.
Many developers understandably
focus their testing
on mobile devices.
So once you see it running on
a big screen in laptop form
factor, often, the
need for optimization
becomes immediately apparent.
So the best piece of advice
I could share there is just
try it.
That said, we've
worked with many
of you and many other developers
to do those optimizations.
So we found that
some of the questions
come down to these
four differences
between mobile and desktop.
First one of those
is wider screens.
And it's probably the
most common issue.
Some apps don't use
real estate like they
should on a wider screen.
So this is stuff that
we need to do too.
This is an older
version of Google Maps.
The new version
fixes this problem.
So as you can see,
the content is
locked in this column in
the middle of the screen.
And there's all of this space
on the sides of the screen that
isn't really being used.
And here's another example.
This is a conversation
from Google Hangouts.
So in this example,
if it's on mobile,
everything flows neatly down
the middle of the screen.
And if you read down
the conversation,
you can go from
bubble to bubble.
But in the case
of a wider screen,
the two sides of
the conversation
are hard panned left
and right, so the eye
has to scan from one side
to the other to the other
to the other.
And it makes it a
little bit awkward.
And this is exactly
the kind of thing
that just becomes immediately
apparent once you see
it running on a larger screen.
The second note is that
phones are default portrait,
while laptops are
default landscape.
So this is an example.
This is a game called "Store
4, Rise of [INAUDIBLE]."."
And it's built for portrait.
Chrome OS respects that setting,
so you're not at your laptop
and looking at it like this.
So we do orient in
the correct direction.
But this is a case where
it's a graphics-rich game.
You have all this
beautiful content
in the middle of the
screen, but these black bars
on the side of it.
Now we know that fixing this
kind of thing is non-trivial.
But we wanted to
share another example.
We've worked with this team.
This is the Bubble
Witch Saga 3 game.
So this is a game
where the action is
happening in a vertical space.
For those of you who've
played this game,
you shoot these balls
up to catch balls
at the top of the same color.
And the action is happening
in that vertical strip,
so what would you
put on the sides?
So this is an example of
how this team has worked
with our team to find a good
solution for making sure
that graphical
richness is spread
a little bit towards
the sides of the screen.
The third thing that's
different is windowing.
Chrome OS, like most
desktop operating systems,
has a windowing system,
because multitasking is part
of the benefit of doing that.
Now many apps assume that the
window size equals the display
size, which makes complete sense
on a regular mobile Android
device, but that's not always
the case, even sometimes
on Android, where you can do
split screen controls on newer
Android releases.
Part of the value of
desktop is multitasking.
And in this case, the
window size probably
doesn't equal the
display size, so apps
need to understand that.
When an input is
coming into the app,
if the input is being read with
respect to the display size,
and the output is
being pushed out
with respect to the app's
position, that can create input
offset errors.
So that's just an
example of some
of the kinds of things
to watch out for because
of the windowing system.
So just being careful
to read and ensure
that input and output
are being coordinated
with respect to
the same artifacts,
that will help eliminate
those kinds of errors.
Finally, keyboard
pointer and stylus input,
which on desktop
machines, enables a user
to be able to input
information much, much faster.
There's lots of
common states here
that are kind of
uncommon on mobile,
so for example, hover states.
I see an icon with an app, and
I want to know what that does.
I can hover over it
and get a tool tip
on desktop, which helps
me understand what it does
before I have to click on it.
So obviously that's an
uncommon interaction.
Another example is
swiping to dismiss.
That's really common on
mobile and very natural.
You're on an email app or a
reminder's app, for example.
And I swipe away to dismiss.
On desktop, that's
kind of weird.
Because you have to
select it and drag it
to the side with a
mouse or a touchpad.
So understanding how the
usage patterns change
as you go from one
form factor to another
will help you build an app that
works in both of these cases.
And those updates
can be really simple.
This is Slack.
We worked closely
with the Slack team
on ensuring that app works
really well on Chrome OS.
If you're in Slack and you
want to send a message,
before we went down the
path of working with them,
you would enter a message inside
the app running on Chrome OS
and hit Enter here.
And it would give you
a carriage return.
So simple change-- hitting Enter
here now sends the message.
It just helps that app
behave a little bit more
like what you would expect
a desktop app to do.
And lots of simple changes can
add up to a much better user
experience.
So as I mentioned, and you've
seen a couple of examples,
we've been working with many app
developers to implement these.
A couple of I
wanted to highlight.
On the left here is Squid.
This is a note-taking
app and a drawing app.
They are taking advantage
of an additional new API
that we've built
into Chrome OS--
super low latency, down
to just 10 milliseconds
is where you can get
down to, and that
makes writing and drawing
feel much more natural.
So many, many apps
in the Play Store
who can take advantage
of this and stylus inputs
are working with us on ensuring
that they can take advantage
of this super low latency.
But also adding
keyboard controls
to games like, in this case,
Star Wars Galaxy of Heroes,
so that users can feel a little
more immersed in the action
when they're running
this on desktop.
This is just a couple.
There are many, many more teams
that we've been working with.
For those of you who are here
from those teams, thank you.
We hope to work with you more.
And for those of you who
we haven't talked to yet,
we'll look forward to talking
with you a little bit more.
So ongoing, we wanted
to see whatever
we can to highlight great apps
to work that work on Chrome OS.
We did this at the
launch of the Pixelbook,
where we highlighted a
number of apps and demos
to press, et cetera.
But there's lots more
that we want to do.
We want to show people
the best of the apps that
are available on
Play and Chrome OS--
features on Play,
in-store demos, websites,
press review kits, pre-loads,
and much, much more.
So we would love you to
come and chat with us
in the classroom at 2:00 PM.
We'd love to work
with many of you
that we are working with more.
We'd love to work with many
of you that we aren't yet.
So please, come to chat
with us at 2:00 PM.
And we'd love to discuss
with you some more.
So with that, I'd like to
have you over to Nathan, PM
on our developer
platform for Daydream.
Thank you.
NATHAN MARTZ: I'm Nathan.
It's awesome to be here.
And I think it's safe to say
that, over the last decade,
phones have become
dramatically more powerful.
The phones that we have today
have bigger, higher resolution
screens, faster CPUs and
GPUs, more memory and storage
than they had a decade ago.
But one thing that hasn't
changed very much at all
is the sensors on the
devices themselves.
We have GPS, cameras,
accelerometers today.
And we had those a decade ago.
And if you think about
it, these sensors
are fundamentally how the
phone understands its place
in the world.
And because they
haven't changed a lot,
I'm excited to talk
about how they're
about to change in what we're
calling augmented reality.
And if you're not
familiar with it,
augmented reality is
basically a synthesis
of advancements in computer
vision with these incredibly
powerful computing
platforms we all
carry around in our pockets.
And what augmented
reality does is
it allows the phone to
synthesize information out
about the world and actually
compute the precise position
and orientation of that device,
understand the world around it,
and allow you, the developer,
to actually integrate
digital information in
the context of real world
objects, which is
exactly where it's
the most accessible and useful.
And augmented reality
is going to let
us do incredible new
things on our phones.
For example, you can
shop for furniture
without ever leaving your home.
You can browse the world's
largest warehouse of couches.
You can pick one that you
want, place it in your room
and see it in exactly
the right scale,
in exactly the right proportions
lit by the real light
from the real window
in the real world.
Because augmented reality
also understands the objects
in the world, we can
actually learn about them
and interact with them
through augmented reality.
So you can finally actually
make a good cup of coffee
on that office Espresso machine
that you've always wondered
about.
Of course augmented
reality is going
to be great for gaming
and communication.
Augmented reality will allow
us to play, have fun, express
our personalities
in totally new ways
and blur the difference
between our digital selves
and our real selves.
And of course, because augmented
reality allows the phone
to understand the world in
so much greater precision,
it's going to allow us to
navigate the world indoors
and out in ways that have
never been possible before.
This is something we have
actually a lot of experience
with at Google.
We've been doing AR
since 2014 through what
was called Project Tango.
And if you're not
familiar with it,
Tango was a hardware program
that enhanced certain phones
with new AR specific sensors.
And through Tango, we
learned an incredible amount
about what it takes to run and
create compelling smartphone AR
experiences on Android.
The challenge for us, of course,
is that, as you can imagine,
this requirement of
a custom sensor suite
limited the rate
that we could scale
the Tango's specific ecosystem.
And one of these that were
most proud about at Google
is that, today, Android is
the world's most popular
mobile computing platform,
with over 2 billion users.
And so what I want to
talk to you about today
is how we're bringing
augmented reality
to the world at Android scale.
It's a brand new technology
just released a couple of months
ago called ARCore.
And essentially,
what ARCore is, it's
an adaptation of the core
innovations and algorithms
from Tango, but all
implemented in software,
so they can run on
commodity Android phones
without any
modification whatsoever.
And as a developer,
ARCore is going
to give you three powerful
foundational technologies.
The first of which is
called motion tracking.
And this is what
actually computes
the position and
orientation of the phone
and updates it over time.
So you can place a virtual
object, look at it,
walk around it, get
closer, move back
and have the object
feel like it's actually
stationed in the
real world, just
like the Scarecrow
on the screen.
But of course, in order to
place that virtual object,
you need to understand
the geometry of the world.
So we have a second
technology called
environmental understanding.
And what environmental
understanding does
is it looks at the 3-D
structure of the world
and synthesizes that
for you in identifying
major features, like the plane
of the ground or the stage.
Lastly, though, we
want to understand
not just the atoms of the
world, but the photons
of the world as well.
We want to understand the
illumination of our scenes
so that you can actually capture
the ambient lighting, apply it
to digital objects so they
feel married into the scene,
and can even react to changes
in illumination, like our friend
the Cowardly Lion
here on the video.
ARCore works on
qualified devices
running Android N and above.
Today, we're in what's
called a developer preview.
So we've limited ARCore
to specific phones.
That's the Pixel, Pixel
2, Pixel XL, Pixel 2 XL,
and the Samsung Galaxy S8.
But we're going to be exiting
the developer preview very
soon.
And when we do,
later this winter,
ARCore is going to run on
100 million Android devices.
And we're partnering with
the entire Android ecosystem
to scale that number
aggressively next year
and beyond, which is an
incredible amount of scale
for a brand new technology.
So if you're a
developer, of course,
you want to use this stuff
and actually get started.
So we have great SDKs for
Android Studio, Unity, Unreal.
These are native easy-to-use
high performance APIs.
So whether you're a game
developer or a native app
developer, you can
actually get started
building for ARCore today.
Of course at Google, we
care a lot about the web.
It's deep in our DNA.
We believe that,
ultimately, the web
is going to be part of
bringing AR to everyone.
And so we're investing
actually in web AR standards
and prototype
browsers that allow
web developers to
eventually have
the same capabilities
as all of you
native app developers
have today.
One thing I want to bring
up that's really important.
All of you are
here because you've
built amazing apps and great
businesses on top of them.
And I'm sure you as you
hear about a new technology,
especially something that
involves 3-D, like AR, you're
thinking, do I have
to start from scratch?
Do I have to build a brand new
app to take advantage of AR?
And I'm very happy
to say that no,
you actually don't
have to do that.
One of the things that's
amazing and great about AR
and has been a design
criteria for our AR SDKs
is that we want to make
sure that you can actually
add AR as an enhancement to the
apps that you've already built
and have users engaging with.
So for some of
you, you may see AR
as an opportunity to start a
brand new business, a brand
new kind of app.
But for the rest of you, you
can treat AR like a new feature,
like a new capability
added to your app.
And if you're a Unity
developer, use our Unity SDK.
Native in Android Studio?
We've got you covered,
and Unreal as well.
So for all of you, you
can add augmented reality
to your existing app exactly
where it matters most.
And then when you're ready
to do something else,
move on to a different
capability or part of your user
flow.
I'm personally
incredibly excited
about this new
technology, how it's
going to allow our phones
to understand the world,
the way it's going to let
us, as developers, integrate
and enhance our
understanding of the user,
of the world with
our display of it.
But if you're still a
little bit skeptical,
we've got a fun video that
hopefully convinces you
that this is pretty awesome.
So let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Thanks.
If you're interested in
building for ARCore, please,
check out
developers.google.com/ar.
It's got links to documentation,
getting started, downloads
for our SDKs, a ton more.
Or, of course, you're here.
Come check out our classroom on
VR and AR later this afternoon
just across the hall.
Thank you all so
much for your time.
We're going to take a
quick 10 minute break,
and we'll see you
back here afterwards.
Thank you so much.